kim kardashian's relationship with pete
davidson is hotter than ever and now a
source tells e.t that when it comes to
her ex kanye west she isn't concerned
about what he thinks or what he's doing
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
e.t source explains quote kanye
absolutely hates that pete and kim are
dating and despises the idea of kim
being with someone else he is definitely
not cool with it as for the 41 year old
kkw beauty founder the source says she
could quote honestly care less about the
women the grammy winner dates
you just gotta roll with it of course
kanye has been spotted out and about
with uncut gem star julia fox packing on
the pda in new york city and la their
second date was even documented by
interview magazine and the 31 year old
actress dished on their quote organic
connection telling the mag quote i don't
know where things are headed but if this
is any indication of the future i'm
loving the ride and she doubled down on
all that during the latest episode of
her spotify exclusive podcast forbidden
fruits for right now like i'm just
living in the moment and i don't have
any expectations i
you know there's no labels there's none
of that it's just people that
make each other feel better it is like
it's really like such a gemini aquarius
like connection a source previously told
et that kim quote isn't phased by her
ex's new romance adding kim is happy if
kanye is happy and she is glad that he's
putting his energy into someone else
romantically but the source told et
kanye is still trying to get kim's
attention
kanye is trying to make kim jealous by
being very public with julia he is
trying to make a point i'm just rolling
with it and it is what it is as for keat
you know kim and pete e.t source says
the two are always laughing together and
constantly in hysterics that was really
funny quote pete brings out a side of
kim that she loves she adores pete's
sense of humor and their chemistry is on
another level the source adds that kim
likes that the 28 year old saturday
night live star is so authentically
himself quote he's also really sweet and
always puts kim first they get along
wonderfully and share a really special
bond i'm so excited about it and pete
well et source says he loves that kim is
such a great hands-on mom and also a
boss
i think my smartest business decision
has been going for it i mean i've always
worked since i was
15 years old i've always hoped that it
would be a big
empire
quote she has created an empire and pete
really respects that she has been able
to balance multiple successful
businesses and a stressful divorce all
at the same time he admires her class
and thinks she is a super mom
now i know what you're thinking what
does kim's famous family think about her
new beau according to et's source they
love him and welcome their relationship
with open arms quote kim radiates when
pete is around and the family really
takes notice of that and respects pete
for bringing out kim's best self i love
that energy in my life of course kim and
pete first sparked dating rumors back in
october after her gig hosting snl
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
since then the two have been spotted
together in each other's hometowns new
york and la they've been traveling a lot
together and now e.t source says they're
making their relationship work by flying
back and forth between the two cities
quote it's actually been really fun and
easy and there's no pressure pete enjoys
la and has lots of friends there and kim
is obsessed with nyc so it works out
well for both of them
[Music]
you